well president President Trump traveled
to India last week to meet with that
country's Prime Minister Prime Minister
Modi one of the central issues at their
meeting was the h-1b visa program that
program doles out roughly 85,000 visas a
year to foreigners so they can move to
this country and take American jobs not
exagerating that's what it does the vast
majority of these visas are given to
people from India as a candidate in 2016
Donald Trump called for ending this
program entirely but as president that
hasn't happened though the Trump
administration has made the visas
slightly harder to get so why is the
program still around why is it so
durable that's an easy question to
answer it's a favorite of tech companies
which claim they simply can't find any
Americans skilled enough or smart enough
to do tech work that's a lie a provable
lie companies routinely use h-1bs as a
mean to fire their existing American
workers and replace them with lower paid
foreigners often the fired workers are
made to train their replacements before
they're terminated the process for the
replaced workers is painful and
humiliating company executives tell them
they're being reassigned to a completely
new company with a new role that
consists of training people to do the
job they once did whether or not needed
anymore they're cast aside we recently
spoke to some AT&T employees who are
quote rebadged by the company to train
cheaper replacements from India here's
their story
[Music]
you're just gonna dumb you know you feel
helpless and you just accept it this
former AT&T employee spent nearly two
decades at the company a few months ago
AT&T informed her that she was no longer
needed I'm aware of at least eight
thousand eight thousand workers at least
eight thousand it could be more she is
one of many former AT&T workers who
found out on corporate conference calls
that she was getting what they called
rebadged to a new company where she's
forced to train a low-cost foreign
replacement today it's my job tomorrow
it could be yours she expects to be
officially fired within a year what can
you do
who can you call who do you talk to you
many have turned to Sarah Blackwell an
employment lawyer who represents
American workers what AT&T is doing is
they're firing them and having them work
for the companies so they are working
for AM Docs
Accenture IBM and tech mahindra and
they're training their replacements
there one former employee is currently
training his replacement told us that
the new workers are all from one place
they are all from India most of them are
from Hyderabad some are from Mumbai our
producers obtained shocking documents
from the training courses PowerPoint
slides with the AT&T and Accenture logos
inform workers about Indian cultural
customs and warn that Indian men will
not shake hands with American women we
are an American company and we are
literally giving away our legacy we are
giving away our knowledge base we can't
get those things back once we outsource
all this AT&T boasts about its corporate
woken us outside its corporate campus in
Dallas but the company gave it soon to
be former employees a list of approved
topics for discussion with Indian
replacements and urges them not to
discuss India's human rights record or
religious conflict in India with their
future replacements their goal is to
offshore as much as they can to low-cost
countries many companies say that the
foreign worker visa program helps US
companies deal with the worker shortage
you would not be firing workers if you
really
had a shortage many tech companies say
that the h-1b hires are smarter than
Americans and better workers to one
former worker wasn't convinced some of
the folks that we work they are very
sharp but we've got some of they were
dumber we would have to water them twice
a week AT&T for its part isn't going
broke to give you a sense of the
company's priorities it's spending a
hundred million dollars on an extensive
renovation of its headquarters AT&T CEO
Randall Stephenson makes nearly 30
million dollars a year that's nearly
three hundred sixty-six times the
average AT&T worker the outsourcing
helps to pay for all that
they said you do not get a severance
package you're not eligible one for one
since we found you another job that's
what we were told we were also told that
we would not get our annual bonus next
year unless we agreed to work for
Accenture when you're watching so many
people suffer at the hands of a few
getting rich and no one's protecting
them then people will stop thinking
capitalism is the right thing to do do
you think that the people who run the
company care about the workers no a
spokesman for AT&T denied that any of
this is happening and assured us that
anyone who's been rebadged can return to
AT&T at any time they say many of those
employees have already been placed in
new 18t jobs where are they it hasn't
happened to you it hasn't happened to me
one of the think I think that's a
blatant lie it's an infuriating and
deeply unsettling by our producer
Charlie cougar
when our leaders cared to put Americans
first